normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
Business Insider writes Elon musk's luck
has finally run out is this it it's the
end for Elon oh no good R Lynette Lopez
writing that uh Elon was on a heater
from 2019 to 2022 it seemed if every
single gamble he took was paying off
then he did what every risk addicted
blackjack player inevitably does he
pushed his luck too far
overconfidence confirmation bias and
delusions of control LED to a string of
bad decisions and boom elon's Empire is
in trouble again oh no oh wait what's
this the richest man in the world Elon
Musk
the truth Elon Musk engaged in political
Behavior defending Free Speech buying a
big Tech platform and is winning he's
got more Fu money than anyone on the
planet Tesla is is slaying it cyber
truck is coming out everyone's super
excited SpaceX has the majority of all
space launches and they're like yeah
well Elon musk's failing because we
don't like Twitter anymore yo Mark
Zuckerberg barely even posts on threads
anymore nobody uses it this is the
narrative you know what I think is
happening is they're trying to scare
other people out of doing what Elon Musk
has done particularly wealthier people
but I think Americans in general it's
sort of they're using him as a an
example of of you know this is what
happens when you speak out when you do
something to go against when you're a
dissenter uh when you go against what
the state says is acceptable they they
want you to think that he's a massive
failure they want you to think that if
you were to even go you know even try to
do what he's done or go even remotely
close to that uh that the same is going
to happen to you that everybody who does
something that gets involved in politics
and takes an opposing position to the
state uh will fail and you will fail too
I think that's what this is part of
because they try every time somebody
does Ventures out and tries to do
something and they're successful at it
when it comes to creating either you
know a parallel economy being a part of
that or doing what Elon Musk is doing
which is actually quite unprecedented
honestly so it's hard to compare it to
anything else but I think more than
anything they just want you to believe
that you will fail if you speak out if
you do something against the state
that's why these articles are coming out
yep they'll take your money they'll
defame you they'll destroy you they'll
take everything that they love from you
but will they be able to stop you
absolutely not look what happened to
Owen Shroyer look what happened to Alex
Jones look look what is happening to all
these individuals that they did
everything to stop and then they have
risen once again back up again and and
and and and this is a big sign this is a
huge case right now that they
desperately want to be true they need it
to be true because if it's not it's
showing people that free speech is
popular it's more popular than what the
corporate advertisers want it to be uh
it's more popular than the FED federal
government and the feds want it to be
and I I think free speech is the big
winner here and even though they're
they're they're saying all this stuff it
doesn't mean it's true look at this
image they made of Elon Musk his
forehead getting red and his money
disappearing the dudes wor $244 billion
he could lose all of Twitter and it's
$44 billion value not to mention he
didn't pay for the whole thing because
he got loans and he'd still be worth if
let's let's say he ate the whole cost of
Twitter and collapsed he's worth $200
billion that's I just I I I I I don't I
don't get it they're just trying to push
a narrative like you were saying Anna
they want you to think that you cannot
succeed doing this stuff who is they
this is I'm not understanding Works
Democrat
okay you're asking who is they though it
is Democrat and neocon party
establishment shills who are mad that
they can no longer control the narrative
it is the CIA and the FBI who had a
direct line to Twitter and lost it and
we're using it to manipulate narratives
but the Tesla and and especially SpaceX
is like tight with the Department of
Defense they need that technology and
he's helping them and working with isn't
he isn't he being sued by uh merri
Garland or whatever whatever happened
with that he has multiple lawsuits
including some for uh uh going after him
for not hiring enough refugees in in
space for some Str
the doj sued him in August for not
hiring refugees despite the fact he's
not legally allowed to I think they
thought they could control him I really
do think they thought that okay well
he's still somewhat one of us he's not
really that into politics and then they
failed and he's you know fighting back
and now they're starting to realize oh
elon's not on our side I think that
they're really they they've lost their
guy they lost because I think they the
the government likes to control the
wealthiest people in the country and
when they lose them when they start to
lose them that's a threat to them
because they have more power and that's
what's going on here and we kind of saw
it with and this isn't really as big of
a deal because they're not quite as
wealthy as Elon uh but what happened
with the company that made uh sound of
Freedom they came after them the the
whole I think it was rolling stone then
a few other articles came after that too
but they attacked them calling them
kinon and conspiracy theorists and it's
like they this is it's the same thing as
this they they want to make you believe
you can't be successful if you provide a
an perspective outside with the accepted
narrative but um but yeah I think he's a
particular threat because he's so
wealthy and they thought that they could
control him I think they did think they
could re regain control of him so this
is what happens with uh we we we put out
a bunch of songs and uh a lot of things
has happen have happened the first thing
is uh Pete parda formerly of The
Offspring uh we we make contact with him
we work together we make a song and when
our publicist reached out to various
entertainment Publications to say former
drummer from the spring working with Tim
pool the responses we got back were go f
yourself and things like that Unbecoming
of entertainment reporters by all means
they could have been like we don't like
this you know you know we're not fans of
you politically but there's news there
in in what we're doing instead the
response was not only are we are are
like not only are we going to ignore
this to make sure no one knows you're
doing it because we we don't want to
give you any press because they View
Press as a weapon they actually emailed
us back we got emails back from variety
of a variety of different entertainment
saying F yourselves and we were like wow
when we reached out to I want to keep it
relatively vague for for um legal
reasons litig litigious reasons when we
reached out to various music industry
groups like here's the standard process
by which we publish music they outright
just whoopsy screwed the songs up
screwed up tracking rejected it and we
were just like wow man and so the
original idea we had was to make a song
mocking the whole industry and then when
I saw what Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles did with together again the story
that Jeremy told was they offered a
substantial like 100 times the market
rate to play a song and they were
rejected and so Jeremy was like we're
going to make our own parody version of
the song from the 60s as like it's like
basically our version of an Fu and spend
six figures doing it and so that's why
we have the song coming out this Friday
I I I don't want to ham it up too much
but I am you know we are promoting it
the issue
is we need to win the culture War the
institutions are controlled the media is
controlled the movie industry is
controlled and so it's not just about
making music it's not just about uh
making movies it's not just about Elon
buying X it's also important to
understand these institutions will spit
in your face publicly will lie about you
outside of the media so this is why
we're doing the best song ever.com this
is why we're making culture and uh it's
it's all aligned with the I don't know
how to explain it I guess more than just
what people realize is captured right
you you'd think oh the big labels will
only sign B no you don't understand the
financial institutions Banning people uh
uh like web services cutting people off
when uh gab had their hosting was it gab
had their hosting Seas right it's been
it's been a long time like there there
are thin threads of
infrastructure in in all of these
different networks where people will
give you the middle finger and try and
shut you down I think that's why music
is so powerful and that writing really
good music over and over and over and
just putting out consistently really
good songs is like not really
Unstoppable but pretty close to
Unstoppable with the radio and shortwave
radio like it doesn't require a lot of
bandwidth to get a song across to
somebody um you don't really need
centralized networks and it changes
people and then the people go and they
seek out who did the song and they want
to listen to them and if you're under
five firewalls behind some mesh Network
on some Pirate Radio out at Sea they're
going to find you and listen to you and
um I think that's the way to do it and
if the messages are in the song and
people don't even realize that's another
way to manipulate the masses into doing
good we are building probably the
largest private East Coast skate
facility for a show and we're spending
several million dollars we're bringing
out pro skateboarders and big uh
industry individuals and we're filming
videos and we're doing it because you
know like
every I think everybody who plays video
games everybody who who likes Sci-Fi
movies has seen wokeness infect their
culture and with comic books and video
games it became very apparent 10 years
ago with like gamergate and for me it's
like I play video games sometimes you
know what I mean I don't really pay
attention all that much so I was like
wow this is kind of crazy here's what's
going on then it came into skateboarding
and it's bad and now I'm like
substantially more irritated and
aggressive because it's attacking
something that I participate in and care
about really really really badly I mean
the woke stuff in skateboarding is is
just absolutely getting crazy and uh uh
uh we see it with Taylor Silverman she's
a female athlete and she loses to se to
males on more than one occasion and
we're seeing more than just that in
advertising in sponsorships companies no
longer sponsor the best skateboarders
it's it's still there for sure but now
there are people who are getting major
sponsorship deals for identity politics
and I'm like we're going to shut it down
and at least in in terms of what I know
music skateboarding Etc we are going to
invest heavily in pushing back on all
these cultural areas I hope everybody
else does as well so seeing rip averse
Eric Jolly's comic books is is man the
victories just keep stacking themselves
up so let's make more of those it's it's
almost as if everything is being
weaponized law fair is being weaponized
entertainment is being weaponized movies
are being weaponized and uh the the
hearts and minds of individuals
especially during a war are key to win
over and and I think this is the kind of
groundwork we are seeing for what could
be potentially a bigger conflict out
there they are trying to win the hearts
and minds of individuals they're losing
look what happened at Disney the Disney
turn around turn around with with Snow
White the Disney uh uh individuals who
of course are are pissed off at the
company which Elon Musk spoke out
against specifically giving a big kind
of Fu to the company and many people on
subscribing from that particular
platform also highlights a a big kind of
shift in people's energy reaction to
towards this as of course everything
woke now is being met with distaste and
and disdain and uh I think it's great a
lot of the people said that Vietnam was
ended because of the musicians of the
time like Crosby Stills Nash and Young
there was a riot at Kent State 1970 May
4th where all the students were out
yelling and the war and the war and the
they thrown rocks at the National Guard
the National Guard open fire and killed
four kids four four adults at that point
and then Crosby Stills naash and young
wrote a song called Ohio about that and
it went hugely popular and it was also
having the video camera is embedded in
the war zone and seeing the horror that
ended it too but those two things in
conjunction woke the music woke people
up seeing it we're in an age of deep BS
now which is makes things a little
strange thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time